you ready for this let's do it
it will kill
the Continental Cavalry saber my name is
Justin Hammond I'm 28 years old I
am a full-time bladesmith and I am from
Lockhart Texas
before blade smithing I was a chef for
about 12 years if I went I just found
out that my wife lost her wedding band
so I'm going to buy my wife a wedding
band the Continental Cavalry saber was
an iconic sword used during the American
Revolutionary War while this style of
Sword was originally built for British
soldiers American bladesmen started
reproducing them for the Continental
soldiers these long curved single-edged
blades delivered lethal Cuts against
British soldiers as the Continental Army
ambushed them from horseback these
American swords were famously wheeled by
revolutionaries during the Battle of
Princeton in 1777 where George
Washington defeated the British retaking
New Jersey and forcing the British
retreat into New York
the scissor my name is Don halter I've
been a Texan all my life I plan on being
a Texan the rest of my life I got three
degrees and nuclear engineering I found
my call in cleaning up radioactive
material decontaminating stuff we had a
lot of Homer Simpson t-shirts
wielded by Gladiators in ancient Rome
the scissor was an ideal weapon for the
bloody battles that had suited the
Coliseum Arena the Contour of the sharp
crescent-shaped blade was optimal for
slashing and stabbing while the armor
encasing the forearm offered protection
Gladiators who used the scissor were
also known as sasortes they could
swiftly brandish the weapon in the heat
of battle due to its surprisingly
lightweight dual block and cut
capabilities of the scissor-free the
user's other arm for another weapon or
Shield giving the user the advantage of
multiple ways to attack
we are in Lockhart Texas and today we
start on the Revolutionary War
Continental saber
I'm gonna build this sword mono steel no
compliance thus far biggest challenge is
getting the curvature just right this is
a long sword man I've got my blade
parameters Matt it's time to quench
taking my time anything can go wrong
when you heat treat
and she worked that's what I wanted to
see I wanted to start getting some
measurements taken I'm about an eighth
of an inch shy on my curve
the only way for me to get the link I
need is to stick her back in the fire
goodbye heat treat
I need to try and get this curve to
parameters puts a lot of stress on a
sword couldn't pick up a crack but I
don't have time to make another one this
Grinch has to be perfect
as long as there's no cracks that should
be okay
oh yeah quenches went well very relieved
to see that who gets to be so lucky to
have two successful crunches
I'm good to go I finished the blade
yesterday so there's nothing left to do
but fit and finish
love it when I finish up a blade on
Wednesday because I get to do all my
hand sanding once watching one of my
favorite TV shows the sword is assembled
it's complete it's sharp so let's go
ahead and test it
it's comfortable I can't wait to see it
tested though
I absolutely love this thing
[Music]
I'm not really familiar with a gladiator
scissor but since it is armoring I've
been doing armoring for about 25 years
I'm sure I can overcome any challenges
that come up for it I'm using a coarse
wrought iron combined with high carbon
steel to make a composite welded blade
I have no idea what that came off of
Just
part of my 500 pounds of stuff
hey man we're Texas we're bigger and
better and our blades are better
my whole Gauntlet section is done in
three pieces the only thing I have left
to do is to make sure all the parts fit
back together there's no warps in there
that I can't take out probably my head
first time
I'm trying to get the main cone to the
hunt it's driving me nuts
there's a slight warp in it
it keeps catching on the inner layer
turn it
oh
that was a pain I don't want to Triple
holding this that would really suck
so I want to make sure nothing's going
to Rattle loose when the judges start
hitting stuff with it that would hurt
now the final test
it rubs on a knuckle slightly but yeah
to be honest I didn't even notice that
until afterwards because I was just
having too much fun swinging and cutting
things with it
ladysmiths welcome to the dynamic kill
test
find out just how durable your weapons
are I'm going to cut through the spring
carcass and these drums just in your
first you ready for this let's do it
all right just a song about your saber
here first up your handle construction
it is nice and smooth it's avoid enough
to where I have a very good grip now for
a saber design I usually see the curves
a little bit up front over here but it
wasn't an issue overall sir your saver
it will kill
you please this is a kill test to see
what kind of lethal damage your weapon
will do I will take your scissor and I
will deliver killing blows on this
ballistics dummy let's have some fun
let's do this
[Music]
foreign
what I like about your weapon is that
it's in Lime with the handle on the
initial cut here it lacerated right
through there and in this backhand hook
your Edge is deep to go in here and
right into that cavity your weapon will
kill thank you
all right gentlemen it's time for our
Dynamic strength test
to test the overall construction of your
blade as well as how it feels in my hand
I'll be attacking our British warship
here
Justin Europe are you ready ready when
you are okay
[Music]
so Justin first off everything's in one
piece Blade's still just as sharp as it
was but having that curve here as
opposed to out here the weight is kind
of behind where I'm expecting it to be
but it did a great job it held up
beautifully nicely done thank you sir
now the scissor was used in gladiatorial
combat for both attack and defense now
to test the strength and durability of
your weapon we'll clamp them into our
mechanical device here the Blade's going
to come down and strike the armored cuff
of your weapon twice and then your
weapon is going to be launched into this
breastplate so don you ready I'm ready
all right let's get you strapped in
so looking at this I can I'm having a
hard time finding where the sword hit it
and there's one teeny little Mark
the Blade's still tight on that edge is
still a razor blade there's no rolling
at all very well done it's nice thank
you
forged in fire war of weapons